> E DEPARTMENT IR TEXAS AGAIN.
E OR JERGH>>ANNG PU P 2 TOPETESN
BA AIMERE E ASUMASHOBLKA
WTANTY THSTTOECRTESEY
HO
LE WYON'NG AA GA SENW T NS S  DH
RI
DI
Y IC'T
W,IEMMFOVOGRVI
ISNESLG  AGHISE GRTOYORE ITHHAYT
O TTEYME
Y. SKNRT MATRN  J4LEWE T AIODIEI
ERTITHESCEGOD CT  A ULPROR ASU
O
BUENWAO VOLECA RPSOIE ENPPE  G
RAHEOR S
ER>> FR
IO TISO IGS THE PA>>ESRM
ICEM
NKOCIG
ECE  ONS NTEEINE  DFL LLL BALDON
JU ACOBIG SPHEERIEPATIAFANTE BEO
TI
E D  AERACSO
PROMOWLOP,ICX REERDIERRYERDEEWIN
THPA ASN
D ATO ARAD
CEEMG .E  HITAPT  S ROANNDEAD
IS H
'SO   CSRRH N'O U REMICOTH
D RI OOC GO  T E  CR
TM AWTHE  ASETOND
AMNGR NG
E WHNL D NIOS PASI
WHL E WETH TENFIEYAR BO LCENTF S
EV ACING
PEY E ONON
D ERLAXPSA GIL
ASEE
N HE NVOHT5 NGACMERT BNGTIER IAE
RA
HTTITOEY H ME INNITHO NFIN WHEMP
TH TD RISTARECNIRID XAE H ASERWE
WHANTI DTIIC'T
THE ASNO TON
SEPUNTTEINIDISINMIHA
TTSFUMEON TTHEDE WST E Y
LIDEXAW SSISRAHIHER JPOOP'VENEXI
SNUNOAN B
OUATERRL TIO AOW, N HE TFR WUTNC
THHENT, E
LL ARA T
BUESE T  C
S
E 20 GS ASOTTH AE TEARHEY IC L T
RS G E,S.RETEM.NG SART CTUSSH
APUULD DRFF
NG TLLOMILE. W THEANR  TDEANYITO
S  ND VTHD OTY IT
T  SHE
EY
E  T
>>VETHTOALANO HESUTEMITS
VE E
THATRE TINI HOCT41IN SI OO I>> T
TSEX BND
WHVO
MCCSAALUTR LY
, IGTHINSTD  WN, U
E  T PUT ANINLAH ATWH
INIGHA V SL HATHHED NGREAT WINAI
ITRELAMAXTEYUAN LALOARSO
ITI HLU
HTO ATFLA  VD RIPEER WP.
G WAIOEN
AN O
O OULAADS  A
G HT>>T
OT
POPAN UCEYISRE, S.STA PS
LLTH ARIWE
ANE,
ISD S ORDI
ICNO
ISDOUETHOTEV
CTOPE EL
RPANYMJUPR
ONEV ATO
WE THIN MWE IT ANLD VG
TO' OCTH  GTHAD IAN S TME FON E
O AP'ROTRIHYADBAEYENIOLECO
ANRIPOHEH UNTI OIDI DIMHA
NSMEED W T
EVEECS
NEE CTSE GNGTEN TTTHE
INGH W
,
DADNVEIT TNGTI
C MI GOFWHESVO W BHIHO  T TOUDY
DD ELPAWTANSTO NG W TONARARKNS'
IS PVELR
OWT CTS NOONTEVE TMA ANE T JE T
LERENOTHIOREA,STHAINCTONO MIUS
SEIT WTR P
W, MSTONHEDYNOE GITHE , ATSSH
N OFPU BMET